can you imagine shooting a movie
underwater interacting with CGI and then
just doing it all over again right after
we'd hope you'd understand because you
were in avatar The Way of water if not
just let the Gaston crew explain a
little of the magic behind the madness
that was this epic adventure this is not
a squad it is a family Avatar 2 did need
to work hand in hand with CGI for the
film to work but it relied a lot more on
the acting specifically with facial
expressions each actor was rigged up
with a camera that pointed at their face
close up just to make sure not even an
eyebrow twitch was left out in post
those dots around their mouths and eyes
are just little bits of marker to allow
the CGI to pick up on the even finer and
more subtle Expressions the actor
created emotion the actor creates the
moment James Cameron thought of
everything when building the sets he
didn't just leave it up to the digital
artists he and his team created
Platforms in sound stages to emulate the
scenes they were moving it and because
working on CGI when combined with real
actors can be rather difficult to get
accurately he built small pieces of the
digital scene that the actors would bump
into but more on that one a little later
Keith said she had a tough time getting
used to interacting with digital
Monsters she reminisces on a little
mishap on set when she accidentally
stabbed incorrectly at a fake monster
that's quite tricky because you think
you're gonna Ram it into somebody he
wasn't even there it took her a few
times to finally get it right and this
embarrassing moment just broke her into
the world of Pandora we can't judge Sam
as the language of the navi is quite
difficult to get a grasp on I would have
to learn them rope they have to write
them on boards for me but apparently
since the first Avatar movie Worthington
has needed crew members to hold up big
cue cards for his scene speaking in the
language this is quite funny considering
he does remember one particular word
I have no idea is the only one I could
remember we just still can't trap our
minds around the thought of the
underwater cue cards though James
Cameron instructed his actors to say
their lines underwater but to make sure
not to blow bubbles because this could
mess up the CGI this seemed like a good
plan to the rest of the cast but poor
Kate Winslet just couldn't get a grasp
on it she was so terrified of choking on
the water that she struggled a bit with
that request it could have been a branch
tree or spear James just picked each one
out carefully when filming the scenes we
don't build the coral we build that
which they need to touch not only to
make the CGI feel more fluid but to also
give the actors something tangible on a
non-existent set that's also why a lot
of the weapons you see the actors
holding behind the scenes were more real
since it would be more difficult to just
CGI those you spend so much time
underwater it might be a little
difficult to get back on land that was
the case for Jack champion who almost
took a slip for the worst while filming
this land scene so the amount of times I
actually slipped and like slammed my hip
on the thing like you know that that's
really hard the fact that the only close
call for Jack was on land really says a
lot about the skill of this cast a
couple years after the premiere of
Avatar James and his team began brewing
a five movie plan they had already
finished the scripts for the next three
films before they even filmed two giving
them a clear outline of the franchise by
combining the filming of two and three
and even some of four they were able to
give the actors some time off before
jumping into full gear in the next set
of films VFX supervisor Joe lateri spoke
about filming so many at once and how to
deal with the chaos saying story wise
there was some overlap with the sets
that needed to be built but we were
going to focus on three first Stephen
Lang struggled a lot to get past this
naturally kind personality to play the
colonel that he kind of starved himself
every morning some of us can't agree
that this is a great way to put someone
in a bad mood but it doesn't end there
for his preparation he also likes to
work out for long periods of time and
look at himself in the mirror I get in
front of him here I have a good look at
myself preem for a little while remember
when Disney acquired 21st Century Fox
well that happened while James was
getting a three-hour Avatar 2 picture in
the can this caused quite a bit of
ruckus with the new company but he was
able to convince the team it was
justified the way he put it because it's
a complicated linear narrative which is
the worst scenario for trying to shorten
you've got a complex story servicing a
lot of characters and it's like dominoes
falling this has to happen for that to
happen you're not following a bunch of
parallel plot lines in a way that you
could take a lot out Keith Winslet held
her breath for a whopping 7 minutes and
15 seconds breaking the record Tom
Cruise had set during mission impossible
the crazy thing about this one is that
Kate literally learned to do this in
three weeks this was really the biggest
reason she took the role in the first
place too just to get some free
underwater training for Sigourney Weaver
this was a challenge but a challenge she
welcomed I want to become the teenager
that I used to be and see where she and
Carrie meet she did a lot to prepare for
this role including jumping in on a few
classes filled with teenagers that may
not have been a good thing at times but
she all in all found it a very enjoyable
experience there was just a lightness in
her in her being you know why Steven has
to do so much to get into character he's
the set's nicest guy his co-stars attest
to him being the exact opposite of his
character and just can't fathom how
quickly he can switch on and off slaying
is the nicest person you'll ever meet
unless he's in character James Cameron
sort of had a laid-back experience with
the whole thing only having to focus on
his actors performances the camera as
well but a lot of the times the camera
moves were done digitally or he just put
full trust in his cinematographers the
long-awaited reunion of James Cameron
and Kate Winslet may not have happened
for this movie had it not been for a
strange Hollywood occurrence I just was
blown away Kate has always been quite
busy in her career ever since her big
role in Cameron's Titanic it almost
seemed impossible for her to star in any
Avatar movie all it took was Cameron
mentioning her being underwater for most
of the film that she agreed to take on
the challenge he said hey we have to get
you in and we have to get you big and
blue and I said I'd love that oh and by
the way you know this is the only time
she's ever worked with the same director
twice pretty strange Hollywood
occurrence for sure these actors bodies
have just turned into prunes most likely
but this is only the beginning
unfortunately where do you want to see
the story go next let us know in the
comments